[Music]
[Applause]
hello hello I know I heard that the last
time that you were here on campus that
you said that if you had how to Stanford
MBA you would rule the world I I wish I
could have done in well I think that to
be in Stanford is such a such an
incredible lucky thing you know you're
in this and then I was told what did the
Dean just say that who is it that just
said that it was all that it was very
important or to also be rounded right
well you don't have a Stanford MBA no
and you rule the world do you think I
should drop out well it doesn't look
like she's nervous right
so DVF you started your career very
early on in working as an apprentice in
a factory can you tell us a little bit
about that experience and if you really
want it to be a fashion designer growing
up I really didn't you know I always
when I talk to young people I also
always say you know unless you have a
real vocation like you know you want to
be an actress so you know you want to be
a pianist or something or an engineer
you don't you don't know what you're
gonna do and then you know when you
start life there are all these doors and
which door is gonna be my door and which
door are you gonna push and it's not
always the most glamorous door that will
give you the most glamorous life my door
was I mean when I went through when I
met this Italian man and he invited me
to come and to you know do an internship
well he had a little crush on me but and
when he invited me to go over and to
watch what you know he was doing I mean
the last thing I was gonna think is that
he that man in that factory would be the
most important thing in my life so I
think it's very open to it's very
important to be very open and to be
curious and to pay attention and to kind
of you know follow your heart and follow
what the universe there is you and then
all I knew is that I didn't know what I
wanted to do but I knew the kind of
woman I wanted to be I wanted to be a
woman who could have a man's life in a
woman's body I wanted to be able to pay
my bills I wanted to be able to do the
same thing as a man did but I didn't
know how and then I found a way and I
was very lucky because it happened to me
for me very quickly as it does now you
know in today's world I mean so many so
many millenniums make it so early and I
was I was I mean I mean at the time they
weren't that many but I was one of them
and I was looking so to that point what
the audience may not know at that time
was that you were also a princess and
not sleeping beauty princess but like a
literal princess when I married a prince
you married a prince but you continued
working yeah and I married pregnant too
so that was I was gonna leave no why I
mean it's you know it's it's one of
those thing I I was engaged okay it's so
important for you to continue working
though when you really oh no no no I had
just I was just starting and but I mean
I didn't want my financial independence
to come from my father my husband I
wanted to do it on my own and I did and
part of you know I was they I mean it
also made my marriage not survive I mean
you have to say the things as they are
so at some point I had to choose and an
eyetooth but he gave me two beautiful
children and we stayed friends for I
learned and by Muslim let me switch
gears a little bit and talk about your
business when you started your career
you created a very famous red dress and
here at the GSB we talked a lot about
product market fit about creating
products that satisfied a particular
consumer need and looking at the
audience it looks like there are several
people with the wrap dress on now if you
have a DVF dress on can you stand up
[Applause]
I think you found product market fit
this dress has been relevant for over 40
years what do you think that you saw in
the market but other people were missing
oh my god it didn't happen like that at
all I mean I mean at all I mean I was
okay I was working I was working with
this man this man had a print Factory
a printing plant it was in Como Italy
Como Italy is basically the end of the
Silk Road right the Silk Road starts
from China you go to all the thing you
go to and then you end up in Como in
Como there were all the silk
manufacturers and therefore they around
them there was an industry there was all
the illustrators and painters and
artists that would sell their drawings
and their paintings to to those people
in order to make beautiful prints
scarves and so on and a print this is a
print so this man so that's what I
learned first he would go there and look
and this and so they buy an artwork and
then you put it in my page and then you
talk to the colorist
and Italy at the end of after the war
was very industrial Italian Italy was
just beginning and so there were these
very very small factories that were
being born and there were families and
these people were colorist and their
grandfather was colorist and the
great-grandfather so it was very like
that you know and this one made handbags
and so anyway this man had a printing
factory so I learned about that because
he was a successful printing factory he
would make all five scarves for Gucci
and say hug amo and people like that he
then needed more room because he needed
more room he bought the factory next
door for the walls when he went in he
saw all these machines that we're doing
anything because the people who had the
factory before we're making stockings
now you all
young you don't know what this stuff is
but starting is what people wore before
they were pantyhose right they were
wearing stockings with little garter
belt
and so stockings was over so these
people went out of business and so this
man looked at the of these machine he
said what else could I do with these
machines because they were tubular
knitting machines and so he called in
all the yarn people do pawn and people
like that and they they tried this
machine with a thicker yarn and that's
how they came up with the jersey fabric
now there are two ways there are two
types of fabrics the fabrics that are
woven and the fabrics that are knitted
jersey fabric is a knitted fabric
it's what t-shirts and made up at the
time t-shirts
nobody would wear t-shirts except men's
as underwear and maybe sailors but
nobody else watches you know nobody else
what he should until there was a very
famous movie star called Brigitte Bardot
and she lived in this little port called
San Tropez and there was a little shop
there when they started to dye the
t-shirts in all colors and there was
busy Bardot looking so beautiful and so
hot with these colored t-shirt that had
a little Central Pier signal on it and
blue jeans and barefoot and that's when
t-shirts started so mr. Farraday my
Italian man started to make t-shirts and
then because he had a printing factory
printed t-shirts and I was there when
all of this was happening and anybody
know the factory that used to make
nightgowns because they had very thin
needles so that he could work this
fabric okay all that is I didn't think
any of this would ever be important in
my life that year my mother gave me a
ticket nan lian ticket to go to New York
to visit my boyfriend my boyfriend
so so I went I went to New York to see
my boyfriend the prince was very
good-looking very handsome he had
everything and you could imagine all the
girls in New York wanted to marry him so
they didn't really like when I showed up
but but I was invited everywhere and
there were all these young designers who
wanted me to wear their clothes and one
was called Halston and the other one was
Steven burrow and there were all these
generation of in Georgia sometimes you
know this generation of young designers
and I and we didn't have you clothes
like that in Europe and so on so I I
when I went back because after six weeks
of visiting a gun I went back to Italy
went back to the factory at that time I
walked into the factory and I just had a
vision I said oh there's something I can
do here I can make samples and I will
try to go and sell them in America and
that's what happened I started to stay
in late at night and work with a sample
maker and the pattern maker grabbed any
fabric that was left over in the floor
and make a few samples then a gun came
back on his way you know he was stopping
from one one Bank the next year was
gonna go to Lazar so he had a summer off
so he on the way to Asia we stopped in
Rome we met in Rome we got engaged and
then he went on and I went back to the
factory and I'm going back to the
factory and with this Italian man you
know who's driving the yellow
Lamborghini and we go from factory to
factory and one day he drops me in Milan
and I'm feeling so dizzy because I think
it's a Lamborghini and I fear I fainted
in the street and I remem
Italian people saying more they Martha
she's bad and I was I was not bad but
but when I was was pregnant so that's
what happened
so then all of a sudden oh my god I
can't believe it I'm pregnant with this
most eligible man in Europe you know
everybody's gonna think I did it on
purpose and I can't I can this is
terrible so I went to Geneva I went to
see my mother I said I can't I mean this
is not my mother said you're crazy
anyway you engage you have to let him
know about make the story short don't
feel obliged you say no no no are
organized wedding for 15th of July so
much for Nigeria but okay fine so we get
my so I go back to the factory and I
said listen I am pregnant I'm getting
married and I'm moving to New York
will you please allow me to make some
samples from the factory and that's what
I did and that's how I made my first
dresses and they would basically teach
your dresses and sure dresses and and I
have no idea and no experience except I
was 22 and I was cute and so I knew what
I wanted to wear and and that's that's
what happened but this happened in the
70s and this was the heart of a women's
liberation movement well then I came
here and and a gun had you know
introduced me to Diana Vreeland blah
blah anyway for so III yes and then this
dress and then there's two so for two
years I had two children in 13 months so
I had one child and then I was a
pregnant again and in between back and
forth to go to Italy and I had miserable
little orders 15 pieces 55 pieces and
the men Italian men we said what are you
crazy
the factory as it please please please
trust me
have faith in me so I would come back
with more samples and like that for two
years and then think and then I had a
little rap top and a little rap top was
basically what dancers ballerinas wear
you know to keep warm
it's called in French it's called cash
cow it's like hides the heart by the way
it's also called a hub of the three
which is wallet with it ended up being
filling my wallet so at first at first
it was a little a little top with a
matching skirt and that did really
really well and then I said well we have
to why don't we make it into a dress and
that was a dress and then I mean I
started I was 22 by the time I was 26 so
7 we were making 25,000 dresses a week
and that's 50,000 sleeves and that's a
lot and and so I and then I was living
this American dream and I read that the
dress
but what I'm trying to say is that
people say I made the dress yes I made
the dress but really the dress made me
because this dress thanks to this dress
I became very more confident I was going
around to women wrapping them you know
and I was feeling confident so I was
sharing my confidence and I was selling
my confidence and then it was a time of
the you know liberation I mean if you
were young in the 70s it was a very nice
time to be young because it was
somewhere between the pill and AIDS you
figure out and so so it was a very nice
time to be young okay so I read that you
named your first dress
Angela after the prejudice yeah you know
why I mean where you read that no there
was there was a dress that had stripes
and I mean it wasn't a very good reason
why I called the dungeon and Davis
because she had been arrested and it's
described what but what were you hoping
I think that was a really bold move to
name your dress after yeah but nobody
knew I don't even know how
I know but by the way I love that Jill
identity she was a she was she was so
beautiful mission strong human yes there
were all these women that popped out at
this time you know there was Angela
Davis and Gloria Steinem and it was a
wonderful I mean actually okay I was a
princess right because I had married a
prince but actually at the time this one
Gloria Steinem invented the world ms/ms
right so you were in missed or misses
you were miss and I actually traded my
title of Princess the BM is because I'm
a FEMINIST yes yes well it's it's kind
of in fashion to be a feminist again it
went away so there's a movement that's
happening right now with women and a lot
that has come up around the mewtwo
movement the time's up movement from
your experience with the women's
liberation movement in the 70s to what's
happening now what do you think are the
parallels or what do you think are the
differences and how do you do you think
that we're fighting for an extension of
something the same thing how do you
think though when I was young we were
feminists because we wanted to have
equality and in many ways and so that
was that but at the time even though we
still you know when you I mean I grew up
like if you were a woman you had your
period and you would get groped that's
just it that would happen men your
bosses would treat you somehow like meat
and you just had to defend yourself
the best way you could but it was part
of the DNA of being a woman
so you did you know and I was lucky
because I because first of all I only
had three bosses and they were all
before I was 22 and and also because
then I had my own business and so I
didn't have a boss and then I also was
in the fashion industry where women were
actually you know it was easier for a
woman time but I'm thinking you know now
in all these other women who had jobs
with with male bosses who constantly you
know would touch them and do that and
and and and the fact that they didn't
want to lose their job because because
they have children because you don't
want to lose yourself you like your job
you studied for your job you'll have a
good job and then you have this big as a
boss and how do you deal with it and so
I think what happened recently is great
I think that is just you know it's one
step ahead and that man cannot a tweet
us as meat as we can treat them as
something else whatever then I mean but
it's it's a good thing it's a very good
thing and and as women and as mothers I
think that it's our responsibility to
raise our sons so that they respect
women but it's it's it's so much
ingrained in society you know that but
eventually it's I don't know I have you
know my mother always raised me like it
was an advantage to be a woman so I
thought it was an advantage but maybe I
was very privileged maybe you know I had
good legs who knows but
but it's it's it the truth is that I
have never met a woman who is not strong
or women are strong but but a brother a
father a religion or very often
themselves ourselves we don't want to
show our strength because we want our
man to feel strong and bla bla bla and
powerful and all of that which is fine
but then there's a tragedy there's a
fire there's something and the woman
gets one child and the other child and
the jewelry and Bob pull up the door and
you see that at the end of the time of
tragedy the woman's strength comes out
and she takes over so I think it's
important for women to know to know
inside of them that they are strong and
it is their decision to show it or not
to show it to do enough but what is the
most important thing is that they know
it inside themselves I think it's an
interesting concept to talk about the
privilege that may be associated with
some women in their careers as relates
to not having to deal with that level of
harassment and I know you had three
bosses before you were 22 right I think
there are a lot of women in a lot of
different industries that don't have
that privilege that's right
so particularly in the fashion industry
when you have an industry that is so
contingent on the success is so
contingent on young women young models
for your role as the CDFA president
which is the Council of the Fashion
Designers of America how do you think
about protecting these young women well
we do we do we have rules we have all
kinds of things that we set up and and
it is incredibly important because I
mean I mean I did try to be a model
is not successful but I mean they that
that is all about rejections I mean it's
just the worst thing to try to want to
be a model because it's it's the worst
and but no as as the CFDA we are making
rules and we're doing this and more and
more and but it's also and I think it's
also interesting for this and for the
fashion industry in particular because
there are women are the prime consumers
most lives the consumer and you do have
a number of very powerful women in that
within that industry but there still
seems to be this power dynamic where
women are still subjected to a lot of
the same things that they are in other
industries and why do you think that is
because we're stronger you know listen
women have to stick together but the
first thing is you know they have to
feel strong within themselves and they
just have to we have to deal with what
we have to deal but together we have to
make sure that we support each other and
industries have to support and I think
that all the things the me2 and time
that has really really been helpful and
and it is a different time you know and
we have to make sure that that doesn't
go away I know you spend a lot of your
time your resources rather social or
financial on empowering women and
women's empowerment and that you created
the DVF Awards awards not long ago can
you tell us a little well it's gonna be
this next year is gonna be the tenth
anniversary
yeah it's yes it's actually my son who
said you know you you do so much for
women you should really reward them and
give
money and and do a prize and then one
day it'll be like a Nobel Prize and so
we started together when I got involved
in creating the Women's Conference with
Tina Brown and then at that time I
started this this prize and it is to any
it was really thinking about my mother
who was my mother was a survivor of
Auschwitz she survived and and so it's
it's to for women who have the strength
to fight the courage to survive and the
leadership to inspire and the women we
have given awards to are just remarkable
most of them are not that well known but
they've done an incredible work and and
and it's been it's been a wonderful
wonderful and then you create a family
over ten years and then you see what
they good and usually they got other
prizes after and then you get to know
them and you know I think that when is
most important is I believe in the chain
of love you know if you pay attention to
people and you know them and then you
help them and then I really do believe
in that I mean I I really believe you
see now I was very successful very young
of a black waiter company obviously when
you create something it won't happen
when Donnie won you know it had many
generation but now I have a woman CEO
that I think is going to really take the
company to the new new world the new
digital world and so what I want to do
for the rest of my life know that I I am
70 years old is the fact that I want to
use because when you are successful two
things happen one you can pay your bills
and two you have a voice and when you
have a voice it's important it's your
duty but it's also a gift and the
privilege to use your voice for people
who have no voice
and and that voice thing and that being
able to share the experience that I have
that because I'm I may be 70 but I
really should be hundred and forty-four
for how much I have lived and the the
different people I've met and the
different circumstances and all of that
to be able to share that and to share my
experience and my knowledge and and all
of that and and so that's what I would
like to do for the rest of my life and
and I know your own study business and
you're all super smart and everything
else and so but my what I would like to
be able to tell people is that women
mostly and this is very much of a
woman's audience oh the other day I
spoke to I walked in there and we're all
man lines and me as I say it's not gonna
go well but it did anyway and is my big
umbrella now my big umbrella is design
your life right and so I have because I
want to do podcast and I want to do
speaking engagement and all of that I
wanted this summer I said okay I have to
structure what does it mean to design
your life right what does it mean and so
because I was in Sicily I drew a Greek
temple and on top of the the roof I
wrote design your life and then I put
the pillars and these are the pillars
that I came up with the first pillar the
most important pillar we all have is our
character because you could lose
everything you could lose your health
you could use love wealth you can you
lose your children you can lose
everything but you never lose your
character even under torture and what
does character really mean character is
really about the relationship you have
with yourself the you know and to have a
relationship with yourself is
it's hard because it means you have to
be demanding you have to be disciplined
you have to do all of these things but
you have yourself as a refuge as a
shelter and no matter what happens you
always have yourself and if you have
that any other relationship is a plus
and not a must and there is nothing less
attractive than being needy you know so
character is really the pillar number
one and it's for in order to to kind of
you practice it every day it's like the
plumbing you know it's like Oh pruning
trees it's all the time you need to work
at it you need to have time a little bit
of Solitude a little bit of silence a
little bit of things so that you know
that somehow you could rely on yourself
number one that's why I say the likely
the first not number one lesson in life
is the most important relationship in
life is the one you have with yourself
villa number two is your body and you
may in your mind your brain I mean you
know we our body we have so much power
in our body we can you know we can
exercise if we can forget about it we
can modify you know the shape we can and
the mind I mean it's only recently that
I realize I mean we have this incredible
computer inside you know I can speak
three languages at the same time and
drive and drink and all of that at the
same time
and and my mind is making me do all that
I mean how does that work you know it's
just amazing but we have to pay
attention to it you know and and and not
not take stupid drugs that would modify
our brain anyway I mean like taking care
of it physically yes so one two three
heart heart heart is a muscle right that
pumps the blood and creates oxygen so
heart is life life is loves life is love
is compassion is is emotion and it's
about to be a human a human being I know
everybody talks about you know
artificial intelligence and all of these
things but I really do think that the
only way we can save humanity is by
being humans and I think that there's
going to be I hear it
I hear a lot of people who all of a
sudden think about being kind and and
and doing things to be human and I just
I mean empathy to you yes and it means
paying attention to the next person and
yeah it's it's being human all of a
sudden being human and having a heart I
think that's the Nexus friend
hopefully I mean we have to compete
against whatever else is happening so
one two three four pillar number four is
purpose and purposes work is therefore
work is your independence your identity
it's your expression it's who you are in
society so I know you're worrying a lot
about that here so I shouldn't talk
about it alone and one purpose and then
you have that's been that and then you
have what I do which is aesthetics what
do you wear how you surround yourself
the power of color all of them and
that's what I have I thought my five
pillars were and then two weeks ago I
was so
to my 17 year old grandson and he said
you forgot nature and I thought yeah
that's right I forgot nature so we had a
normal filler and because and because it
was six and I like odd numbers I had to
add another seven and and and my opinon
number seven was rituals we do things
every day that we don't even think about
like many years ago I did three coffee
table books they were photo book
photography books and one was called a
bed the bath and the table and the bed
you know if you think about it people we
throw ourselves in the bed without
thinking and we go and sleep in a messy
bed look at what the bed I mean how
important we conceived in a bed we make
love in a bed we're sick in the bed we
die in a bed I mean you know so this is
the ritual of the band and the ritual of
the table what to what do we need and
how to eat and you know the pleasure of
that I think there's a whole rich who
are these things that we do or even the
bathroom the privacy of the bathroom and
whatever so all of this is the Beyonder
design your life and does that sound
interesting to you why what I mean I
don't know so I mean I said to I mean I
said it to somebody and say well that's
very generic I say yeah it's generic but
what is engineering I think what isn't
generic is the experience that your
mother had and the influence that she's
had on you as a result of her surviving
Ashwin's you talked about that a lot in
your book the woman I want it to be and
I would love to know how that that
influenced the woman that she wanted to
be
all right so in order to describe my
mother imagine yourself in 1944 in
Belgium occupied Belgium by German this
22 year old girl gets arrested deported
and sent to labor camps in Auschwitz it
was because it was so late I mean she
stayed there for a while and then they
it was the famous death march name went
to another camp and then another camp
and 13 months later she ended up in this
third camp and by then she was in pretty
bad shape and and one morning they woke
up and the Germans had left and then the
Russian came and raped them and whatever
and then they left and then the
Americans came and they she was in a
very bad state she couldn't move she was
brought to a hospital she weighed 49
pounds and and so they made her feel a
questionnaire the only reason I know
that is because I the Holocaust Museum
who I have that I have did a huge
research on both my parents and sent me
all this information and I this question
there comes and they say name first name
second name where you know where you
came from and and then state of health
and even though she could not move she
wrote excellent health and that explains
everything you know no matter what she
always told me no matter what happens
you can never be a victim you know and
she survived she gained the weight back
my she her fiance came back from
Switzerland they got married the doctor
says you have to wait three to five
years before you have a child because
you won't make it and the child won't be
normal and nine months later I was born
and I was not normal
[Applause]
so my mother my mother used to say to me
God saved me so that I could save it so
that I give you life by giving you life
you gave me my life back
you are my torch of freedom so I was
raised with a lot of risk you know I was
supposed to be the total freedom at the
age of one I had to speak I had to speak
in public you know my birthday I mean I
always had to memorize my mother was a
tiger mom she was tough and she would
not allow me to be afraid if I was
afraid of the dark she would lock me in
the dark closet today she would be
arrested and after 10 minutes you
realize that there's no reason to be
afraid and so obviously I'm very much a
result of my mother my mother you know
so never be a victim doesn't matter what
happened bla bla bla
this and that and that for me you know
but when you ever very strong mothers
it's you know you have to wait until
she's gone for you to accept it you know
so we're gonna do a quick lightning
round we have a couple minutes left I
would love for you to finish the
sentence sentence I feel most confident
win I feel most confident when when I
speak to a nice ground what angers me
most is oh I don't get angry very
quickly what angers me more most is when
I witness lies the thing people would be
surprised to learn about me is the
things that people would be surprised to
learn about me is that
[Music]
probably you certainly do my superpower
is Oh
my superpower is my magic one which I
use every day when I try to my first
email of the day I tried to use I try to
do something that doesn't benefit me and
I will introduce one person to another
person I don't have to leave a message I
don't have to speak all I have to do is
write it perfectly and explain
everything well and I may have changed
that person's life most important advice
I can give for this audience is most
important advice I can give is the one I
said before is that the most important
relationship you have is the one you
have with yourself
[Applause]
[Music]